less than a year into this
administration and the one thing that
joe biden's presidency has already
taught us is that he has no respect for
life we saw it when biden checked his
watch as the bodies of american soldiers
were presented to grieving families
their lives cut short at the cost of his
awful decisions in afghanistan and then
he made it all about himself when he
spoke to those gold star families as one
of those fathers recalls
he talked a bit more about his own son
than we did my son and that that didn't
sit well with me
and we see it in his war on the unborn
where he is pushing his doj to overrule
texas's abortion law that protects the
lives of babies in the womb
joe biden sold himself as the empathizer
in chief but the last few weeks have
shown joe biden to be anything but
empathetic joining me now is former vice
presidential candidate and alaska
governor sarah palin
welcome governor
thank you so much
so as the mother of a veteran
tell me what you think about how joe
biden president biden has treated the
military since he's been elected
it's it's a shame and those in the
military who will candidly boldly
express their opinion they share that
opinion that it is a shame that their
commander in chief their leader would be
so blase about um
lives of america's finest who are
serving something greater than self
they're literally they are serving
um
people who though who have
suffered
underneath the hands of joe biden
are very frustrated i think a lot of
them feel defenseless they feel helpless
even in wondering hey is the rest of
america going to be outraged also and
say enough is enough and do something
about this the collective rising up
and actually doing something about the
problems that the leftists are causing
including
just decimating the morale
decimating the organization that is our
military yeah no absolutely i think a
lot of americans share
what you just said i think they really
feel that way and it's just not
resonating with our media who's trying
to tell the story and turn the page
you know i i can't get i have to get
back to what i said in in my in my intro
i think joe biden was sold as the
empathizer in chief and somebody with a
lot of compassion now we see him in the
texas heartbeat bill he's using he's
actually using his administration he's
using his doj to go after pro-lifers
people who are just trying to protect
the unborn uh trying to protect the
disabled and those with special needs
who are often the victims of abortion
what does all of this all together say
about joe biden's moral compass
well do we see a pattern here we do uh
he who would not embrace a culture of
life not understanding his catholic
faith even hey where are the bishops in
all of this by the way
but his catholic faith and any
judeo-christian
even you know agnostic
beliefs in
how important it is to protect the
innocent to protect the defenseless joe
biden it does that doesn't resonate with
him and we see that in his pro-abortion
stand we see that in what he has done
with americans in afghanistan
you know you can
this is some people are going to say
this is a stretch but it's not we can
equate this culture
of death that has been accepted by too
many on the left that being snuffed out
the life of an innocent child in the
womb and we can see now a culture that
is allowing others opportunity to
create death around innocent people
speaking of afghanistan so if americans
are good with this
then we're going to see it continue and
it is a slippery slope and we can see
what's coming next yeah but americans
are saying no this goes against
everything that we believe in terms of
understanding human life and god's
creation and
the purposefulness of every child and
every innocent person who happens to be
abandoned in afghanistan right now again
the two issues do correlate they do
enough people say we're not going to put
up with this then no longer will we have
leaders we will unelect these leaders
who are creating this slippery slope
we're on yeah you know governor i want
to ask you about something else you know
there's another catholic who's um
prominent and coming out um against the
uh the uh heartbeat bill in texas her
name is aoc she said this and i want to
get your reaction to it because it's a
little bit kooky
let me play the clip for you
i don't know if he is familiar with a
menstruating person's body in fact i do
know that he's not familiar with a woman
with a a female or menstruating person's
body i'm sorry we have to break it down
on you know break down biology 101 on
national television
so governor she's talking i know she's
talking about greg abbott but she's also
talking about menstruating persons um
this is of course the uh this is of
course the crowd that follows the
science i don't know about you do you
know anybody other than women who
menstruate or have babies
wow aoc she's really milking this isn't
it she's such a fake feminist that she
would bring up an issue like this and
try to use it to make some kind of
political point that that's not that's
not equality right it's oh man don't
even get me started on this this just
makes my stomach sick what she has done
she should be embarrassed to
even have tried to bring up an issue
like that and make her political point
she's so off-base politically but
off-base even in um this analogy or
whatever it is that she's throwing out
there she's she's milking the whole
female thing and as a real feminist i'm
embarrassed for her yeah a real feminist
is one who knows that they are capable
and they are equal they are capable of
doing a lot more than aoc gives women
credit for yes we can give life to a
child and at the same time pursue
education and pursue career and take
care of our other children or give a
child up for adoption if we do not feel
that we can take care of that child
right she has no idea she has her world
view is this big she has no idea what
it's like to be a mother of a special
needs child what it's like to be a
mother of a veteran what's what it is
like to be the mother of a teenage
daughter who finds herself in less than
ideal circumstance all these things that
the rest of america we do we do face and
we're able then to make judgments and
make our decisions on those life
experiences
she's got this much and she's running
the show
well governor you have had all those
experiences and that's why people like
you you you tell it like it is i really
am grateful that you would come on my
show tonight thank you thank you
governor
you're doing a great job thank you okay
thank you sarah hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else